i asked you guys to send me funny ha ha
clips if i laugh i will have to donate
money to you i've sat on a hundred
buckaroonies let's do this oh
before we begin shame on you
shame shame on you only six people
try to rickroll me damn i guess the meme
is dead
now
we've all been in a guitar store there's
that one person
in the corner absolutely shredding away
face melting licks
the best you've ever heard
and you finally sit down to try that
whole guitar
that you've been staring at on a
computer screen for months
and then boom
what the hell do i play
nothing
i'm pretty sure i can play guitar
no
[Music]
i must know at least one riff
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay i don't know i i totally forgot
sped spending made that video and posted
by daniel is betting himself
congratulations
all right
100 big ones
performance anxiety gang can relate oh
my god how is that possible
oh cause they linked it differently are
you idiots
oh it's cart
why would you do that
help me lord i'm dying the sound of me
wouldn't hit the rock
it's okay i can laugh i am a pescetarian
all right chris supper bunch congrats
car dealership red flags part one so
what do you think do you like this
tracks i love it do you have it in blue
car dealership red flags part one so
what do you think do you like these
tracks i love it
uh yeah
a cherry donation would be in it well
then
charity it is
yeah we can probably play slot pitches
after this slot [ __ ] there's a bunch
of tablets women now again it's art
isn't it yeah you wouldn't blur the mona
lisa when elise is not naked
she should be
i decided that one didn't count
you can't catch me i'm the fastest thing
alive
i was thinking about why so many in the
radical left participate in speed
running huh the reason is the left's
lack of work ethic why go fast rather
than do it right and in a peterson sense
petersonian to elevate alternative
sexual archetypes in the marketplace
fastest hedgehog shadow what the [ __ ]
are you talking about you're a beta male
sonic
autumn gotham oh huge that was huge love
that [ __ ] all right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah absolutely congrats jiva
rivers 13 congrats
oh boy
you're a [ __ ] beta male sonic
christmas is saved because we're
bringing back the pewdiepie rhino shield
case collection we're back with 10 new
exclusive designs
i'm super hyped for these
yes
thank you rhino shield for being
responsible with your packaging we
appreciate it
these are the greatest cases in the
business yes
oh
they nailed the designs man they're so
cool
look at that that's dope as hell hell
yeah hell yeah let me replace my old one
thank you very much
not only are these the best looking
cases you can get they're also the best
quality cases you can get because now i
got my rhino shield on i can do this
i broke my camera but now my phone baby
let's go
if you combine rhinoshield's uh screen
protection with the caves it's like the
old nokia i mean you can indestructible
and considering how expensive phones are
today there's really no excuse not to
especially i mean oh boy sorry it's the
first time i see these in person don't
they look sick
cool it's japan which i can't be in a
strong contender i love the color on
this one i think i'll change it is a bad
boy that's so safe but the classic wave
pattern is available in 20 different
colors
which in itself looks amazing i don't
know i always like to customize that
this is the iphone case version
and you're gonna get different color
buttons different ram
uh choose your design that you like so
really customize it and make it your own
which is something i always enjoy with
my own products they got collections
with snoopy pac-man keith herring yeah
perfect gift for christmas or for
yourself for your for a loved one who
knows check it out i recommend it
everyone's always satisfied they're
lifetime warranty baby and here's the
best part there's a black friday
promotion right now all products are up
to 60 off okay
i'll take the whole stock thank you they
ship worldwide with free shipping for
qualified orders uh they're available
for all iphones and android flagship
devices i mean i have the pretty strange
phones and they still have it so check
it out whoa okay and if you're not
satisfied with 60 off you get another 10
off if you enter the code pewdiepie in
addition
check it out don't be that doofus that
has a screen that scratches up right
away protect your phone and look good
doing it link in the description sorry
for going on i just really like it
you know it doesn't matter that i did
that on with the video
[Music]
yes
finally someone
did it
wonderful oh this is great this is great
eric skodak congrats or and whoever made
that clip a great father great father in
the making oh boy
donkey love sound of violin
that's adorable
[Applause]
[Music]
this is kind of sweet yeah no funny just
nice
[Music]
small dumb dogs are my weakness man
hey make a threatening sound
oh i'm sorry man
nathan hell yeah 100 big ones let's go
pretty pleased with the clip so far you
got some good scratches
it's beautiful
[Applause]
oh you're the greatest
[Music]
painful that was painful i've seen it
already otherwise i would die
oh children crying it's the funniest
yeah bernard you knew i liked that clip
well done bernard all right oh god oh
look oh look oh look
what's that clever man huh i don't have
paypal because i'm norwegian you know
norway no reached me
god i hate spongebob's memes so much i
hate i hate them what is that
cheese on broccoli
that's a lot of cheese so cheesy
[Music]
oh that's really good that's really
funny i really wanted to laugh at that i
just read the title hate it when they
start conducting you're not ready
[Music]
see i only passed it i already passed it
i don't have to laugh danish language
okay
the worst language of them all even
worse than which has always been
impossible to understand for more
scandinavians yeah that's the reason yes
it has been impossible to understand for
us in denmark too
so for me the danish language has
collapsed into meaningless sculptural
sounds
yep
yes
[Applause]
okay this is exactly what it sounds like
for us as well like swedish people are
supposed to understand danish but this
is
oh man it's one of those things we're
like
you need to speak english like we both
speak english can we stop pretending
like anyone understands
[Music]
god damn it i've seen it damn i'm just
in a giggling mood today man jeebus
doesn't want the video doesn't want the
money jibbers all right fine fine jebus
you just want to be in a pewdiepie video
there you go jabez
that's pretty good it didn't make me
laugh though
that's pretty good you didn't get me no
that's pretty good
i will not eat a single morsel of food
until margaret thatcher is dead and
buried she died three weeks ago
we'll be we'll be right back with
larry's thing
i miss norm already man
oh god bless adam packer thank you for
sending that in
[Music]
um
that was close i was close all right so
welcome everybody to the meeting of the
piers as you know we do this meeting
every single month to make sure we agree
on things so let's just get started
cheeseburgers yeah hot dogs yeah donuts
yeah bar fighting yeah bug collections
yeah
okay well that's it that's uh the
meeting of the beers has commenced uh
see y'all next month
[Laughter]
jaloni congrats
[Music]
is the dog okay
we should fear the strong
calcium i can't believe i left that that
was garbage and generate that is what we
are going to try to do
[Laughter]
and generate that is what we are
okay don't get paypal oh cool
great
congrats all the winners that was really
fun don't forget to check out the new
rhino shield and i'll see you next time
bye bye